c'est les montagnes et la alors moncany
la christophe dechavanne qui peut
arriver à tout moment pendant sa
chronique ça dérange soit tu l'as d'or
et c'est ton premier producteur a pas de
souci ah ouais pas ce qui va nous parler
de the wall voilà parce que the wolf a
continué sa non pas deux jamais tu
n'arrêtes pas aux américains mais enfin
petit enis en résistance je sais que tu
chantes rien à fond je suis une banane
flambée en tennis
j'essaie mais je suis encore apprendre à
servir qua non jure c'est vrai est
battue va me servir à la cuillère est
une année très bien de commencer à faire
moi aussi je mets une cravate faire
plaisir à ma mère scooter il va très
bien merci madame combal on l'envoie une
ambiance au programme du bac 45 ce soir
des images de la reconversion de moloch
momo moque un peu de questions pour un
champion a bien évidemment j'ai regardé
puis un gros point super beau on
commence avec un toit erc
c'est tout ce qu'il fallait voir heure
par heure aujourd'hui à la télé sauf que
c'est lui qui a donc cédé 48 heures je
me faire défoncer sur twitter c'est pas
grave on adore
10h43 samedi on a réalisé que la chaîne
l'équipe recrute ses consultants amende
de lire leur cv et risquent d'être déçus
ça répond oui bon bien sûr qu'il va tu
nous rejoindre en famille l'équipe
l'étoile de bessèges ces cinq
participations pour christophe riblon
combien d'histoires
17h43 sur france 3 carine teyssandier
reçoit ses candidats visiblement ils les
croisent en loge avant un sage sur
france 3 à l'appui d'un dock un joli
petit hic 10h30 dimanche on a trouvé
téléspectateurs qui s'est fait arnaquer
en achetant la barre traction 2002 m6
boutique aux enfants de ce matin
candidats les amours à une réponse
beaucoup trop spontanée on est partis
pour un bon vivant je pense pas quand
elle se regarde dans le miroir qu'est-ce
qu'elle se dit evelyne elle se dit mais
qu'est ce que je suis je suis grosse ça
fait juste avant l'émission n'a appris
que cyril hanouna et l'inspecteur
derrick aurait un enfant ressemble la
photo nous est parvenue certains qui est
très beau
bien et tout ce qui fait quoi
quel bel attelage
comme tous les ans j'ai maté le super
bowl c'est plus fort que moi sans doute
les restes de mes quatre ans de relation
avec queen bee au total 110 millions de
téléspectateurs ce 110 millions de plus
que les rois du barbecue
c'est vrai qu'on avait plein de trucs
forcément forcément si mal super bonne
ça va vous regarder à une heure du matin
heure française les patriotes et les
eagles ont fait leur entrée dans un
stade bondé dans une ambiance jamais vue
digne des plus belles soirées coupe de
la ligue sur france 2 alors pour ceux
qui connaissent pas le foot us c'est le
seul sport où l'espérance de vie au bord
du terrain est d'environ trois minutes
c'est compliqué comme le veut la
tradition avant le début du match
l'hymne américain est interprété par une
grande star américaine cette année
c'était binck c'est beau sauf que juste
avant elle avait oublié son chewing-gum
la finc c'est moins glam a le choix la
mi-temps était assurée par justin
timberlake à danser comme jamais bien
sûr
et nous a fait penser à ça il a même
joué du piano
justin de regarder la joue du piano
c'était beau symbole c'est beau ça
continue piano continue
[Musique]
mais ça nous a fait penser à ça
parce que carrie la fin de l'année en
ceci est une parodie mais sinon on se
fait défoncer un vrai c'est un ouais
vous êtes beaucoup défoncé ça n'arrête
pas les gens vous en êtes prête pas
vraiment préoccupés à saint macaire
série de matchs du super bowl toujours
j'espère que ça va vous faire marrer
autour de la table parce qu'au prix où
on va payer ces images là je profite
quand ses 15 balles de rien c'est pas un
cadeau que c'est vraiment faire d'effort
[Rires]
[Musique]
bien j'ai rien dit on est vraiment
obligé de les blâmer pas oui j'aime et
enfin c'est payant quoi assez payant sa
cb christophe dechavanne message était
dommage c'est très bien non non on a
fait le montage ya pas de soucis on
participera toujours à faire une grande
cagnotte mais public on est tous comme
tu vois là un truc comme ça qu'on va
lâcher qu'avec les images qu'on va
diffuser la france 3 il faut 8 prime
alors voilà forcés voire rire quoi qui
voit là mais là c'est le meilleur moment
de votre ville isabelle j'ai très peu
non mais là c'est 5 millions de dollars
les 30 secondes depuis vos salaires n'a
rien à voir mais c'est vrai des
candidats chinois aussi diffusée sur w9
ça fait des audiences de dingue parce
que personne ne connaît les règles c'est
fait savoir dans des audiences de daix
commercial qu'au des règles ne vous êtes
des petits veinards w9 ont pris un pro
pour tout expliquer cette année problème
il est aussi clair que isaac entre elles
te donne le prix des pubs du super bowl
si j'ai des joueurs spécialisés d'attac
et certains en défense
quand vous avez ballons en attaque vous
avez donc les quatre chances pour faire
dix gardes mais on voit la quatrième
chambre ou troisième chance si une
française peut trop loin pourront donc
renouveler la possession du ballon on
devait donc dégager le ballon
il faut que la balle traverse la liste
de l'en but et sans kachan vous pouvez
transformer vous avez le pied ou
transformés avec une passe ou de courses
et si vous rapprocher d'un adverse mais
que vous les trois tentatives voulait
passer votre premier cas vous pouvez
donc tenter un coup de pénalité ou un
entre les poteaux qui vous rapportera
foot américain s'est pas que de la
violence aussi beaucoup de tendresse
comme un coup de foudre entre deux
joueurs des équipes adverses
le regard sur joueur est bon et surtout
à empêcher avoir le nez
bonjour mais l'aîné gauche rien faire
pour être des palmes mais mon moment
préféré dire c'est qu'en deux joueurs
des patriots encourage à coups de casque
avant le match national d2 qu'on peut
pour tromper m.koussa peu trop fort pour
lui tout est dit
[Musique]
parce qu'on a une chance inouïe
le cadeau encore longtemps et ce en quoi
ces jours c'est le joueur le fruit plus
haut qui participent le sida le croisait
tous elle chérit tant qu on n a plus qu
ils aillent voir un peu côté j'ai aussi
regardé les jeux de france 3 ce week-end
sa moindre des choses pour une fois
qu'un invité ce bar pas pendant ma
chronique
alors pourquoi plus que sur lui il y en
aura deux pourtant ta chronique chez
christophe de chiens qui adoptera deux
invités oui j'ai vu des choses dans
questions pour un champion bien sûr
juste on commence avec slam animé par le
petit jeune qui va bien tu récupérer
tous les jeux achtung achtung samuel
c'est cyril féraud bien sûr alors série
est tellement il se lâche on aime
beaucoup celle il fait plus attention en
double sens parfois hyper gênante ses
phrases mais les candidates cl tu peux
t'amuser julien beaucoup vous avez été
très bon franchement mais regardez ici
quand je vous dis quelle histoire de
génétique là dedans quand la fille est
bonne la mer est bonne aussi en ce
moment à france télévisions on sait qu'
il ya un petit peu des restrictions
budgétaires
mais à mon avis là ça devient dur ils
m'ont presque fait d'appel à chantal
goya est ce qu'on a pour dix pandas on
n'a pas perdu tant d'argent trop cher
elle c'est un peu dur et bien devinez
quoi c'était jour de paye ça y est les
nouveautés du moins nouveau moi tu
démarres sur france télé ça fait plaisir
un animateur
[Musique]
ça y est ça y est on a remarqué vous
aviez un tic samuel c'est de vous
répéter tout ce qu'on vous dit en
plateau on dirait qu'il ya de l'écho
quasiment sur votre plateau c'est
quelqu'un c'est le havre le apr critique
club doyen du football français le doyen
le à qui a été fondée par des étudiants
anglais le wac a été fondée par les
étudiants soit entre religieuse 1872
1872 ça c'est une histoire familiale via
les lots 8 et béni oui oui les
neuvillois neuvillois texte s'en va être
sans la lettre la lettre ce biais
famille qu'elle va amener sur le plateau
son petit neveu patrie les fans de
l'émission a fait ce qu'on a cru
jusqu'au drame c'est votre neveu est
alors mis l'audi
on m'a dit que tu aimais beaucoup
question pour un champion oui c'est vrai
tuerie je regarde souvent oui tu veux
qu'on passe entre christophe porquier
[Applaudissements]
et
vous êtes sûr que les gens savent que
parce que j'avais la radio christophe
salle à manger
pardonnez-moi bien mangé j'ai pas mangé
non je ne crois pas non mais vous dites
n'importe quoi tout le monde le sait que
ta chambre
non parce qu'ils m'ont dit non il a
réservé donc c'est pas grave j'ai
attendu sèchement dehors c'est pas que
j'avais gibier ma doudoune ont été
choisis mon jour m'a dit non j'ai pas
mangé je souffre et moi dans la gueule
non de demander un témoin quant à moi
non non pas vous non plus on va parler
des photos christophe du connu j'ai
connu un tout jeune en fait on n'a
jamais dit avant les cravates
ouais c'est vous qui le produisent et
oui c'était pas votre premier truc c'est
si bon si c'est bien sur quoi cela reste
un jeu sûr je sais même plus été mais
non il m'a fait faire pour n'a fait
plein de sketches ensemble et où j'ai
été très bien accueilli ces cagnottes
voilà arribas et la boîte de prod de
cowes et y est mieux chez h2o on a d'un
bureau aline son tennis et le plaza
côtoie la question je suis content de
vous voir mais je suis ravi d'être bon
en fait l'espace arien battant 2000 ont
fait camille abbès et termine vite c'est
à dire entre et je rentrais en voiture
je voulais qu'on voulait qui fait du
tabac non mais henry schéma ttf avait
tant donné je suis abonné orange
j'essaie d'en profiter un axe peu galère
l'événement sur tf1 ce week-end c'était
heureux juste quelques trucs qu'on a vu
on a découvert que le frère d'une
chanteuse parle exactement comme homer
simpson c'est assez rare même
[Musique]
mika et obispo sont hyper complice ça
fait plaisir ça marche bien c'est mignon
sauf au moment de se faire un check on
sent que c'est pas booba et carris quand
même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas trop mon band ma soirée c'est
quand une chanteuse revient dans le sas
avec nikos et sa copine petit moment de
solitude pour nikos qui pensait avoir au
moins un petit becquet mais non
[Musique]
une année
alors arrêtez c'est l'émotion ben c'est
normal elle vient de sa prestation au
niveau d'une petite rue calme sinon
métal tombazis je vais laisser parler je
dis ce que tu dis qu'on a le temps il
est 20h sakur tan deux heures george
clooney baggy lunettes de soleil même la
nuit j'ai regardé les maternelles
j'adore gars qui abat avec un sujet de
fond qui concerne tout le monde
aujourd'hui
en particulier ce qu'on te laisser
traîner leurs chaussures dans les prés
des loges de cyril janin bars et ses
légions
malheureusement je dois vous couper
parce qu'il est largement temps de
parler
kkg dans cette émission avec benjamin
pas nous parle sinon depuis les une
semaine les journalistes de la matinale
de bfm préparer la couverture d'un
événement exceptionnel le transfert d'un
bébé requin dans un aquarium
ce matin le jour j on y était enfant
n'allait y assister c'était sans compter
sur la technique de bsh net à l'aquarium
de paris où l'on organise ce matin le
voyage d'un bébé requin c'est génial
effectivement un déménagement assez
exceptionnel de l'aquarium de paris vers
celui de la rochelle il est là acheter
c'est à vous mais oui roanne qui nous a
offert un lapsus qui lui ouvre grand les
portes des bêtisiers de noël de m6 de
tf1 dont il faudra faire les oui quoi
médias du brossage at du but
christophe vos émissions grand reportage
sur tf1 dit maurice hinchey jeu oui oui
oui là ils adorent bien sûr madame
dernier c'est vrai autant longtemps que
j'ai pas pu mais je sais que comme ça de
non j'aime bien que ça dure dans le
dernier numéro tremblement de terre chez
les people ça concerne quelqu'un que
vous aimez beaucoup cyril m'a fait de la
peine
regardez ce qui le fit nil bleu pour
mich où il est passé au rouge ça lui va
bien on a failli pas le reconnaître un
pont michel pas son jour c'est quand
même
[Musique]
66 minutes ils ont interviewé au chant
plus sur m6 sous la pluie de paix pose
aujourd'hui sur tf1 ils ont aussi suivi
une équipe d'un terne en médecine qui
prennent une photo de groupe
et attention s'élèverait fera pas demain
bienvenue voilà c'est quand même
vraiment austère un brin de folie s'il
vous plaît même folie le globe des
blouses blanches ont mangé toutes les
compotes du réfectoire et on a aussi
regardé un reportage sur le tir à l'arc
et en changeant les images sur le
commentaire tu pourrais penser qu'il
parle de quelqu'un d'autre mais
d'arriver sur le circuit en 2006
exceptionnels a-il fait vraiment partie
des grandes stars de la discipline à la
halle est meilleure mais c'est quoi ces
vivante et même pas d'où ça sort ça
c'est pas de chance
horloge est trop bien filmé ça voulait
interdire les petits trucs d'attraper
des speakerines sur les grandes chaînes
on s'est dit c'est dommage on an'a pas
sûr c'est vite qu'avant c'est vrai que
tous les programmes et comme toutes les
filles de la table sont sont très
occupés moctar a bien voulu essayer
c'est plein avec speakerine de ces armes
moqué à l'antenne
c'est vrai ça fait plaisir et a6 mokhtar
fondé à ça du césar
[Musique]
bosworth est devenu dans le programme du
soir de mokhtar à 21h sur m6 l'amour est
dans le pré cette comptine d'heure mais
avec des agriculteurs qui cherche
l'amour puis après cherche la merde
parce qu'ils veulent tous pêcheurs
canadiens marchand n'achète à ce soir
sur ces huit seven comme tous les mois
sur ces 800 quartier côté si vous le
ratez ça sera diffusé le mois prochain à
21h et fx hitman agent 47 c'est des
types qui tuent des types qui ont tué
des types que deux types ont voulu tuer
mais qui sont fait huer par d'autres
types tf1 comment les trois nouvelles
prendre de ouf enfin non je déconne
allait sortir le bouffon
[Applaudissements]